i was on sauce cass yesterday with adam
and an interesting panel
we had some great discussions about
dating and relationships and women who
want kids and women who don't want kids
and
how they'll feel in 20 years and i
thought this was an interesting tick
tock that got a lot of play
on this very topic and i want to get
your take on it i'm going to let it play
in full i think it's important uh very
very important conversation then we'll
talk about it
my body belongs to a man i haven't even
met
yeah okay here's the thing she's 100
correct i don't want children i've been
saying that for 10 years now and i have
pcos so my reproductive system tries to
kill me once a month
or more
giving birth and having a child is my
literal
worst nightmare and my doctors know that
they're fully aware of the fact that i
want nothing to do with having a child
out of my body if you do great good for
you
and you know what option has never been
brought up to me even though i'm on two
forms of birth control at the moment
tying my tubes and the reason i'm given
every time is what if your husband wants
children look last i checked from sex ed
it takes two to tango
i
so
she's brave i kind of love her
feistiness and her attitude she looks
very young to me i don't know how old
she is but she looks young um
so i'm guessing i didn't read the
comments on this one i'm guessing you're
going to have people saying you might
change your mind so this is an important
message though that i think needs to be
heard
there are women in this world who don't
want kids
they don't feel that calling they feel
called to other things now oftentimes
it's not because
they don't have any maternal instinct
like those sometimes make amazing ants
amazing um you know will
amazing like figures in other young
girls lives amazing teachers around
children
um oftentimes they have pets that they
you always like oh you're holding that
little dog like a baby like you know so
it's not a reflection sometimes of not
having a maternal instinct it's a
lifestyle decision it's a lifestyle
choice
and not everybody has a pull toward
being a mom and that has to be okay
you know i had i had hartley late i had
hartley when i was um gosh he's so i'm
43 and he's two and a half so there you
go
had him late i was pregnant late and i
went through so much of my life getting
hounded like constant like do you want
kids well you better hurry up your eggs
are gonna dry up oh oh well you you know
and i would always say i don't think so
like i really don't feel like i'm
being pulled toward that it was constant
constant constant hounding you got to
leave these women alone they're on their
own journey right not everybody's on the
same journey
not everybody's on the same journey just
let them figure it out now of course
could she change her mind one day like
say she goes she gets her tube start she
has pcos that's i don't know if you know
what that is but it's it's not easy to
deal with it's a it's a disorder and an
effect that oftentimes you have to be on
birth control pills or something else or
you know if you go a holistic route
there's ways to address it but it's very
complicated and involves a lot of pain
and discomfort and oftentimes a very
challenging
pregnancy if it can happen at all people
should do some research on that just to
understand where she's coming from
um but she may change her mind right so
when she walks into a doctor's office
somebody a doctor has a responsibility
to say listen you make this decision
it's final
so be sure but it's ultimately her body
and i what drives me crazy about this
discussion
is the pressure and the assumption that
everyone should have children not
everyone should have children now look
for me it worked out differently i met
somebody i changed how i felt about it i
was never going to get my tubes tied i
was always open i was open even though i
didn't think it was for me i was open
and now it's like i'm mom above all else
so people can change their minds they
can meet a partner feel differently all
of that these are her mistakes to make
make but i will tell you that when you
have a woman out there who says she
doesn't want kids and all you do is
hound her over and over again it's going
to make her
be on like she's going to resist even
more
she's going to play that devil's
advocate she's going to push back even
more because you're bothering her
let her figure it out for herself it's
okay to choose a different way of life
and maybe look i said yesterday on
saucecast i said i think that women who
get to the age of like you may feel this
way young she's very young you get to
the age of 50 and you decided not to
marry and only focus on career and you
decided you know not to have kids i do
think that a lot of those women
wind up feeling like like something's
missing
not all though some of them are really
happy not having kids some of them look
at their friends who have kids and don't
want that lifestyle some of them don't
want it at different stages of life of
course there's a biological clock with
women and there's you know eggs and all
this involved that men don't have to
think about in the same way but
you're not going to get somebody to
change their mind this is the memo
you're not going to get somebody to
change their mind by harassing them
about it
that's where she is today on kids
that's how she feels there's tons of
women who feel like that let them be
let them do their thing
let them figure it out some of them will
change their minds some of them won't if
they don't they're not meant to be a
parent
last thing you need is a is a woman
having a baby and being angry about it
and resentful about it
that helps no one especially that kid
so remember that in this debate if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]